kim kardashian has the ultimate girls
day with her daughters north and chicago
everyone gets along everyone loves each
other i'm rolling with it the beauty
mogul documented their trip to the
american dream mall in new jersey giving
a glimpse of their fun-filled day which
included a stop at the aquarium
[Music]
up next a stop by the amusement park
check out the trio riding the swings
kim north and shy also took a trip to
big snow where they've created an indoor
ski resort
in july
the reality star shared this selfie with
the caption skiing in the summer at the
american dream mall must be my fave
thing to do of course she's referring to
her last visit to big snow there's kim
showing off her skiing skills last month
[Music]
yeah she's a great skier so it wouldn't
be a surprise if her kiddos become just
as good as her one day yep now
four-year-old shy may not have hit the
slopes on skis but she enjoyed her time
sledding down the ice
and while it seems north is usually by
her mama's side on these getaways where
loving that shy got to come along on
this one too i love that and get this
it's take two for kim who did a similar
trip to the mall with her boys saint and
psalm last month
[Music]
turns out it was kim's work trip but
they made time for some fun remember
when they crashed her instagram live on
their way to the tonight show what's the
matter mr man missed a man
say hi hi
this is called instagram live hi weirdos
hey stop it hi vloggers if you're
watching this i hate you hey
hey look what you're teaching them yeah
it didn't stop there the little ones
also couldn't keep quiet during her
appearance on the show uh
i'm hearing kids guys can you stop
this is like your first time at work
with me you're kidding me
your kids are right there um
well that is
you just gotta roll with it but at the
end of the day even when they get a
little out of line kim loves being a mom
i mean just i think after having kids it
just is such a life changer our life is
so different i feel like this is when
life really
begins we're hoping to see more cute
moments like this with all her kiddos
[Music]
you